have you had to sum up your drag race
experience in just a few words how would
you sum down this crazy ride you've been
on Oh with this crazy ride roller
coaster roller coaster full of
excitement
um as far as my run on the show baby
roller coaster roller coaster this is
just the beginning for you keep on strut
and girl now sashay away
takes a real [ __ ] from the hood to do
this so to the top to the moment it's
like all the emotions that you could
think that you would ever have you have
it you have it in in that moment and
then some and then some what you hope
The fans walk away thinking about you
well I really hope that the fans see a
little bit of themselves when they see
me they realized that I'm a real person
that I'm like their home girl I am your
home girl America so gone here I let
your girl subscribe you know follow me
on all my social but yet that I'm a real
person and that you know although drag
is my persona all of this is a creative
manner it comes from a creative manner
did you walk away with any friends for
life out of this game oh I have left
this experience with so many sisters um
a couple of us are like thick as thieves
like me and silky thick as thieves a
kyria Devonport coming into the
competition we knew each other and she's
actually my drag sister from Dallas and
coming into this it actually brought us
a lot closer because we have this
experience that only a handful of us get
to experience so to have that and to
have her be there with me was amazing so
yeah I have a lot of sisters